Los animales a la Constitución.
El Presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador
quiere poner un alto
al maltrato animal en todo el país.
Ya sé que en algunas ciudades,
como en Ciudad de México,
tienen sus castigos para quienes
abusan de los animales,
pero resulta que en el resto de México no hay leyes
federales que lo prohíban.
AMLO comentó que durante 36 años se aprobaron
cambios que beneficiaron a unos cuantos en la época
neoliberal. Ahora quiere cambiar eso
y una de sus 20 propuestas es hacer que maltratar
a los animales sea un delito
en toda la nación,
luego de que recientemente un tribunal
levantó la suspensión
temporal de las corridas de toros.
Esto desató una furia en las organizaciones
defensoras de los animales,
que están pidiendo
al gobierno que haga una encuesta
para decidir si se prohíben o no.
¿Qué piensas acerca de esto?
Te Leo en los comentarios y para más información
síguenos en a tiempo punto TV